sound like bro eating all my clothes in
the shower grass I'm gonna fight this
man and now and I was crying right
Oh crying like that man too big to be
fight congratulations on retirement man
[ __ ] not about to retire you all knees
post is that right the mall you had some
incredible years with the Kansas City
Chiefs what are some memorable stories
that you may have with either Annie Reed
or Larry Johnson yeah I got there
Johnson man start me off a Larry today
man Larry chirp me like a brother when I
got to know him buddy like when I first
knew my rookie it was kind of rough you
know you come in you get a lot of haze
that's rookie coming up so it's my work
here you have to bring food to session
guys so I forgot to bring food one week
in and it's my first time I was really
seeing Larry get outrageous on my lunch
man sound like man I get you next time
so I thought you know I thought he'll
just let it go and the next practice
came coming in I was I had a good
practice smiling laughing everything man
go on my play cuz I know I know I'm
every every week day was getting
somebody when did you realize that was a
close fight this man and now I was
crying right Oh crying like that man too
big to be fight everybody try to
convince them to talk me out already
I know my mother fire all right mom I'll
call you back I'm calm my girlfriend
and as you know I like they calmed me
down like man okay how about a hit him
head his helmet is easy I don't do that
mom what you wear how the locker room
man
[Music]
my poster give the equipment got to
drive man I was just sitting down with
my little Taiwan man my little my little
scoop so I had to wait to get dry
clothes about 40 minutes by 25 and so I
mean I mean I'm the only one they're
sitting there everybody went home I'm
waiting for my clothes to get dry off
about equipment god it was a good time
getting that playbook but but I didn't
feel bad because a couple weeks later he
slapped one of my homeboy ties cuz he
did Michael Cox he can tell you today
man he brought he brought a still man
you know this man keep making this play
one way or another you don't want to pay
for fool you don't make it you can't pay
somewhere it's all like you gotta bring
some so I'm shipping doughnuts
whatever you want Danny's okay every
zone awaits you but he got a subway Sam
I got subway so I'll meet like him dude
I saw it it took me one time it always
take me one time for my lessons thanks
for kicking it with us subscribe to be
our to check out more dope videos like
this one